eu estou calmo é o marcel pó legal ver
como é fácil
são paulo a lei da água
não é nada grave é que não recebi mantém
e aí que alex silva ronaldo você está
tudo ótimo agora bom agora tá ontem
estavam que outra foi assistir bruxa de
blair toda vez ao filme de terror lines
assistir vai obrigado que esse gene
parabéns a peneira de bruxa é o que eu
mais tenho medo fui me cagando para
comprar você me dá um ar bem em gases em
gaia senhor não sei tendo com jesus a
beleza com pelo negócio comprar pipoca
sentei num começa com a tela aprendendo
assim esse filme é baseado em cenas
encontradas na não sei o quê em 2014
ótimo jesus brigado em 2014 um dia
desses eu posso nem fingir que antigo
negócio nunca foi baseado em fatos reais
na história que aconteceu um dia deixar
dois anos nem pôde inglês coldplay o meu
deus
a história é a seguinte a bruxa chama
bruxa de blair book porque a bruxa a
cidade chamada black e ela era dessa
cidade tão pouco debate político do
piauí
e aí aconteceu os fatos nem foram as
pessoas lá numa casa mal assombrada e
morrer as pessoas lá e aí não voltaram
mais a irmã do rapaz ele desapareceu
nesta casa é o cara quer fazer o que a
rolar na casa salvar minha irmã para bem
já faz um tempo nexus nunca vai lá e
aparece uma mulher para fazer um
documentário sobre o cara que vai
procurar a irmã vai também junto ou não
deu num às vezes eu penso que os
personagens do filme de terror pois
assim será que esses personagens não
assisti o filme de terror - resolve lá
na floresta mal assombrado mas com a
câmera filmando toda hora como a gente a
vir meu deus eles pegam a câmara começa
a filmar entra num carro seus amigos bom
para a floresta mal-assombrado que matou
esquente e volume floresta nem com
passarem vivo veja lá o que matou gente
já fica com raiva já vai ter um dos
meninos que acredita muito espírito só
que tem outro que não acredita em
espírito e fica deve achando que
acredita tem tempo ruim fica o senhor
deve estar sentindo nada espírito tão
bem já morreram nessas lojas e lendas na
posicionada que ambas
o kaká eu acredito que já vi símbolos às
vezes nas pedras indicam um coisa de
espiritualismo ninguém morreu criança
não bastasse existe um negócio tão a ser
besta ver isto eu acho interessante que
eles vão caminhando eles vão conversando
um assunto como se fosse normal da vida
pois é cara que morreu oito crianças né
pois é caros que pegar as crianças
matavam por 1 e jogava no posto depois
quebrava a cabeça com a um dente né
achava o crânio acho que sabem que
pegava os adultos que eu cortava os
braços enfiavam no cool e depois é fazer
entrar até sair pela boca é interessante
não é rapaz pois é que pode uma coisa
dessa
e depois ainda não estava a cabeça e
jogava batia 3 machadinho dava um nu de
bicicleta naquela briga só é a mesma
então falando a sério é que foi o jogo
no tempo normal assim o que só conversa
saudável de falar você acreditar e
quando matar uma criança nessa área aqui
ninguém matou - ninguém que não gostar
do vencedor o imbecil caetano história é
esse país que é do estadão defeito com
riachos e conta a história do rio acha
se acha que morreu a mãe afogado e
quando ela ia morrendo em vez de salvar
a criança puxa outra profunda e matou
todo mundo é um outro assim honra o
fatalidade não foi santana vamos
atravessar o rio embora esse povo é tu e
eu olhava o japão vai pro negócio de
sair num fait rafa não valeu a
parrillada não eu to the não vá aí fora
talvez ainda na fila indiana por
caminhão também a pesquisa
a mulher contou pelo caco de vidro eu
falei caiu só pênalti pra mim é o
seguinte o filme de terror é normal
acontecer qualquer coisa uma mosca
entrou na minha sopa satanás para
envenenar promover a corrente da
bicicleta caiu satanás tentam travar
coisa pra quebrar o meu caminho para
conseguir chegar à igreja tinha um
cachorro eu deixei por satanás satanás
revisando todos os leões podem ser causa
dessa e não podia ver está amarrado num
dia no getsêmani phone que meu jesus
chorou jazz ao louvando o que eu penso
que é o diabo não foi na versão cabine
dupla e arriscavam a cantar porque é
assombrada floresta morreu gente no rio
no rio gente afogado mas vamos tampar
recomeça martinelli o cara vai contar a
história o carinho que acredito em
espírito começa a contar a história da
bruxa de blair bruxa de blair é uma
bruxa acusado
de matar a criança agora essa bruxa
amarraram ela num palco eu digo é uma
equipa muito gabriel um pau só mas eu
vou mandar não amo paul uma árvore e
deixa pra lá de amarrada numa árvore e
deixar lá para morrer dizem que foram
procurar a bruxa depois de não tinha nem
sinal devem até que foi comida por
criaturas da floresta dizem que a pessoa
morre de susto só de olhar para ela é um
bichão que não acredita nas coisas pai
emitir alertas abertar beijo tchau
ribeiro esse negócio de blush blush não
ao corredor boy dois estavam dormindo na
todo mundo pensa que não pode encarar
tudo com esse susto mulher um tiro na
floresta que espantou todo mundo todo
mundo na minha barraca começou aí
comentava todo mundo bem todo mundo bem
todo 123 4 faltando um caminho foi minha
honra a nossa floresta sombra ficava sai
de madrugada pra mijar rolan cada título
ninguém respondeu uma pessoa que vai me
já não tá escutando espanha não foi
mirella foi kaká ataque como escutar o
barulho do suspeito quando o carro caiu
para fato o botão da caatinga foi canal
hoje eu ia ficar porque eu já ficava ao
ano todo o estado tem um golod cita um
golo de som ou [__] floresta melhor
neve deixe-me já no gazineu não só nunca
maltratou nunca mas nunca fui mais
imagina chapa vai procurar o carro de
madrugada na floresta sombra já morreu
gente amanhã que a mulher portuguesa que
já matou a criança que busca chamar a
atenção que o carro vai procurar o amigo
que foi me jael não procurava olhar faca
de fulano sumiu sumiu de gohan ou
infelicidade né galera vamos dormir que
amanhã caldas e da então procurando cabo
marques que não prega a gente pára
sério mesmo amputaria machucar de novo
embora não passava pra casa ae a
doidinha que cortou o pé não consegue
mandar o gps como funciona o carro
ninguém sabe onde é que tá eu digo
pronto agora acabou acabou pra gente que
galera olha o que está me dando mais
medo desse filme é que não tem trilha
sonora ligar aquela trilha sonora que
deixa os onze tipo assim fpso
não tem então fica assim o ambiente aqui
ó
quando o susto vem não sei nem se é
justo no silêncio qualquer coisa
espantosa de boquim o forró ayew fica
mais real ainda assistir o filme ficava
em um dia de semana e funk jesus eles
vão dormir a mulher pode despertar do
dela para 7 da manhã quando desperta
obras como estava em noite não fica mais
de dia aí pô
só fica de noite agora do tipo na ilusão
a comecei a ficar com medo quando ele
sai todo mundo dentro da barraca bicho o
acampamento está todo cheio de pedras
imbu em pendurar daquelas coisas o irmão
até aí o filme estava tranqüilo só
naqueles surge então aquelas coisas que
têm sempre todo filme tal tal mas o que
não tava tendo de erro até aí o eto oeo
tá todo mundo parado a pessoa que não é
afeito a quebrar os ossos melhor se
revirar o sonho de título só deu tempo
pra virar pra cima eu vou começar a
gritar a sua música do escritor
o cara que não acreditava no espírito de
ficar só um bando de tarde sarney deixe
que nada escrito não beijo e sai pra mim
já pensou que não tava viajando só um
vulto passando a ligar ea morrer porque
não se fundiria uma com uma pouca
mandando-os outra inversão da auchan já
está todo mundo correndo gritando
pulando outro bicho reclamou rafael
promorar eles vão ver a sua casa pra ver
a casa de chá chá casa é ter memória
diminui campo natan que está eu não sou
daquelas pessoas que eu falo como surgiu
essa mistura não puser um bumbum ao cabo
fábio chega da casa começa toda aquela
coisa que aparece gente corre no lugar a
diego não vejo uma pessoa de costas
chorando por canto da parede ou é o
capeta é doida começa sob a pessoa mais
uma vez a particular mas daquele show
que só o capeta fazer discípulos é o
banco que a casa se uma pessoa que
aparece mas se eu fosse a todo esse
filme eu encontrasse com o capítulo
final do filme dizer olha realmente a
estrutura aqui sinceramente um dos
melhores viu a pixar parece mesmo villa
mix muito louco viu parabéns a pedro que
acontece no final aí você vai ter que
assistir né eu assisti na estreia bush
leva nos cinemas de todo o brasil olha
só você que é bem pertinho já está com
vários vídeos carregados aqui já quer
fechar esse né não esquece clicarem
gostei aqui em baixo tá isso é muito
importante
muita gente a assistir o vídeo dá risada
pra carai sai e não creio que gostei
então não se esquece que invoquei volta
do meu facebook onde eu sempre peço para
você curtir lá vídeo novo dia que eu
achei bruxa de blair clique em curtir la
marca seus amigos nos comentários no
facebook gosta de de filme de terror ou
que está interessado em assistir ou que
não assistiu ainda eu quero que você
comente aqui embaixo que você fica mais
indignado quando você assiste em filme
de terror tem uma votação que estou
participando de melhor paródia neste ano
então se você quiser me ajudar é só
clicar no primeiro link na descrição do
vídeo e da rt é só um tweet que eu tenho
lá e você deve ter lá no tuíte beleza
vai tá me ajudando se inscreve no canal
pra sempre pegar vídeo novo quando saí
tamo junto é nóis em que ela falou